foreign
well I regret to inform you my friends
that the nurses are at it again we all
remember the coveted days when nurses
across the country were posting
choreographed dance routines to tick
tock constantly complaining about being
overworked and understaffed even as they
turn the hospital's hallways into a
scene from High School Musical it was
annoying it was insufferable and it
exposed a troubling weakness in the
nursing community that is their need for
attention
which is of course a weakness shared by
almost everyone in our culture among
nurses it was put on display yet again
uh with a slightly different style of
video this week NBC news reports four
labor and delivery nurses at an Atlanta
Hospital came under Fire over a tick
tock video in which they shared the
things that annoy them about expecting
mothers and their families the nurses at
Emory Hospital or Emory University
Hospital Midtown were participating in a
popular Trend where users share their
icks or turn offs about a person The
Tick Tock Trend originally began as a
way to for someone to describe why they
stopped dating another person
I can already tell you one of my icks
which is people using the term ick to
describe their pet peeves I know this
might come as a shock to Tick-Tock users
but we actually don't need a cutesy new
slang term for everything
now I realize that every generation is
entitled to come up with its own slang
but this latest generation has grossly
abused that privilege
there should be laws governing this like
if I was Theocratic fascist dictator I
would allow
maybe three new slang terms to enter the
Lexicon every 25 years
each generation gets to pick three
not three in a week but three total
in any case bringing it back to the
nurses not to jump ahead and spoil the
ending but according to NBC it would
seem that they have been fired uh so
it's quote Emory Healthcare said the
video was disrespectful and
unprofessional and does not represent
our commitment to Patient
family-centered Care we've investigated
the situation taken appropriate action
with the former employees responsible
for the video the company said an
Instagram post
so former employees
possible never specifically confirmed
that they were terminated for the video
but I think we can logically assume that
they didn't all happen to retire
Suddenly at the same time so it appears
therefore that this video was a bad idea
here it is
my egg is when you come in for your
induction talking about can I take a
shower and eat what my ick is when you
ask me how much the baby weighs
and it's still and it's still in your
hands dad comes outside and asks for a
paternity test right outside the room
door saying you don't want any pain
medicine no epidural but you are at an
eight out of 10 pain just a servino and
you're still closed fingertips well
we've already told you to push a call
light but every five minutes your family
member come back at the front desk
excuse me can have a blanket another egg
when you're going room to room between
one baby mama and your other baby mama
oh Nick
I see that it's the unlimited trips to
the nurse's station for me
well ladies the good news is that you
don't have to worry about any of those
icks anymore the bad news is that you're
going to discover a new ick which is
called unemployment don't be distracted
by parties and presents this holiday
season instead join Hallows most
anticipated prayer challenge of the Year
pray 25 led by cast members from The
Chosen the largest Christian streaming
Series in history pray 25 will guide you
through meditation and prayer for 25
days leading up to Christmas pray 25
will help grow your understanding of
mankind and develop a disciplined prayer
habit during a season when discipline
can be really put to the test hello is
the number one prayer Christian Prayer
app in the U.S and the number one
Catholic app in the world hallow helps
me make prayer a priority and with pray
25 it can do the same for you find peace
and fortify your faith this Christmas
with hallow download the app for free
join the pray 25 challenge all you got
to do is go to hallow.com Matt Walsh and
get three months completely free that's
hello.com Matt Walsh to reclaim your
piece during this holiday season if I
can understand why you were so
frustrated it must be difficult when
your patients are a bunch of domineering
prima donnas constantly making
outrageous and haughty demands for
exorbitant luxuries like
food and blankets
next thing I know you're going to tell
me that they even sometimes request
anesthesia before surgery
I mean these are these are divas we're
talking about now I admit
there might be something uh there might
be something to some of the the
complaints they Lodge in that video it
wasn't all unreasonable I would also be
annoyed and kind of grossed out by a man
who has two children being born by two
different women in the same birthing
unit though that sounds more like the
plot of a 90s comedy starring Eddie
Murphy than an actual real life event be
that as it may
some of the complaints seem valid and
I'm sure there are plenty of nurses out
there who could make many other
complaints even more valid and
defensible than the IX these ones
outlined in fact I know they could
because I have nurses in my family and
I've heard the stories
but there there are two points that
these ill-fated tick-tockers failed to
understand and these are lessons that
all of us no matter our careers would do
well to keep in mind
first you go into the same job every day
okay you have helped hundreds of
patients if that's your job so you have
been asked for blankets and food
hundreds of times and and every slightly
annoying or silly or thoughtless thing a
patient might say or do you've
encountered dozens and dozens of times
so you feel
the cumulative effect of all of those
little annoyances
but your patients don't
so this is a job to you this is
something that you punch in and punch
out of every day but if you work in the
labor and delivery unit for many of your
patients it's a Once in a Lifetime
experience on average these days it's
not any more than a twice in a lifetime
experience nobody is in there having a
new baby every three days unless it's my
wife we're talking about this is always
the tension between employee and
customer employee and clients employee
and patient
you're both involved in the same
experience with the experience is
fundamentally different for both of you
because of your roles
for you it's a job but not for them
so part of your job then
is to not bring your weariness and
annoyance into the experience
yes you've been asked for a million
blankets yet the patient asking you for
a blanket right now isn't cognizant
about that or thinking about it and
shouldn't have to
you should treat the patient like their
needs are the most important thing to
you and then treat the next patient
exactly the same because that's what
you're being paid to do and it's
difficult but that's what you're
supposed to do no matter what your job
is you're running a cash register at
McDonald's each pay each not patient
each customer who comes in you know the
the number one value meal you you've
you've punched that in a thousand times
but this should be them you should act
like this is the most important thing in
the world to you getting this person
their Big Mac
yeah you're faking it but that's your
job is to fake it
second everybody complains okay there
there's no sense in complaining about
the fact that people complain people
complain about their jobs about their
families about their personal struggles
their health problems Etc everyone has
complained about all of these things
but what people seem to not understand
these days is that there is a proper
time and place for these complaints and
there are improper times and places
there are appropriate forums and
inappropriate forms there are people in
your life you can can and should
register these complaints with and
people you shouldn't
and making a complaint publicly on video
for the entire world to see is very
rarely the correct time place Forum or
audience
generally you should be complaining to
someone who a
can actively do something to solve
whatever problem you're having or B is a
trusted Confidant who can listen and
provide you with meaningful support
so if your complaint is something that
nobody can reasonably solve and it's not
serious enough to Warrant the
consultation with a trusted confidant
probably best if you just keep it to
yourself
because stifling a complaint telling it
to no one ever
is also an option and one that should be
selected far more often than it is
when it comes to complaints about your
job just on complaints about your family
a great majority of them will fall into
this last category
like they're complaints that you should
just never tell anyone if you could
believe it there should be there should
be a whole list of complaints that you
have
about people in your family about your
job that you never tell anyone
because there is no one in your life who
needs to hear all of that or should have
to
grenin Barrett
and and the rest should be articulated
to the appropriate party within your
family or your job they should almost
never be aired in public for the entire
world to hear because the public can't
do anything with your gripe we can't
solve your issue for you
we don't know you we aren't your friends
so we also can't act as you're trusted
confidant
all we can do is listen to your wines
and think to ourselves wow I wish this
person would stop whining that's all we
can do with it
and then we get back to our own lives
and our own Petty annoyances
whatever you were hoping to get out of
the public airing of your grievances you
almost certainly will not get
unless in these nurses cases they were
hoping to get fired in which case
mission accomplished and not to add
insult to injury but I must also say
that along with being fired they are
today uh needless to say canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you